I want you to take these three
challenges and build what you think
would be the best Saturday night in
Indianapolis first is the skills
challenge right now we're alltime all
time first person that comes to mind is
dwade Steve Nash I'm going put him in
there I'm going to put me in the skills
I feel like I got cheated Jason hit that
halfcourt shot of me I should have me a
skills Championship us three and then
I'll put in Chris Paul Three-Point
Contest got to put step I'mma put Ray
Allen in there Reggie Miller sniper in
there for the last one I'm going to go
Chris Mullen last is dun contest put
Vince Carter one I'm going go put Zack
LaVine that dude got bounc I'm going to
give Aaron gor some love cuz he even
though he ain't got love for winning one
he could have won one and then I'm going
go a Human Highlight with
[Music]
Dominique